aujourd'hui on va se parler audio on va
se parler audio parce que si vous
cherchez une solution pour venir écouter
de la musique que vous voulez des
écouteurs mais que pour autant vous
n'aimez pas les bugs vous n'aimez pas
que ça rentre dans vos oreilles de
conforte vous plaît pas ou alors tout
simplement qu'il y a aucun bug qui tient
dans vos oreilles ça arrive à certaines
personnes et bien j'ai une solution qui
est extrêmement intéressante et qui
vient de la marche ce sont les open fit
c'est donc aujourd'hui une vidéo qui est
réalisée en partenariat avec Shox et son
dû me voir ils m'ont dit écoute grue
est-ce que tu voudrais pas présenter nos
derniers écouteurs à oreille libre je
leur ai dit écoute-moi mon vieux choc
pourquoi pas on va regarder ça j'ai donc
essayé et je vais vous donner
aujourd'hui mon retour sur les open fit
de shox est déjà à l'oreille vous avez
donc savoir s'ils sont intéressants
surtout s'ils sont faits pour vous allez
c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
16 millions de sportifs qui sont équipés
et tout ça à travers le monde alors je
vous passe le côté il y a beaucoup de
brevets beaucoup de R&D qui est fait
derrière pour venir vous proposer des
produits très cool pour venir profiter
de votre musique oh notamment ces
nouveaux produits qui ne sortiront
aujourd'hui les openfises alors les
openfits sont dispo dans deux couleurs
vous avez soit un petit beige comme ça
qui est très mignon très sympa c'est ce
qui est ce que j'ai aux oreilles tout de
suite si je vous sors regarder
l'écouteur vous allez voir ça c'est le
petit budge le petit beige d'Open Fitz
est fabriqué dans un espèce de silicone
tout doux alors vous c'est peut-être un
peu compliqué à vous rendre compte mais
en fait ça va être ça cette base de
silicone qu'on va avoir qui est
extrêmement douce très très cool donc on
a soit comme ça soit en noir donc là
vous choisissez je sais pas quel est
votre préférence est-ce que vous êtes
plus team belge ou team noir marqué de
moi dans les commentaires donc là vous
avez vous écouteurs qui viennent se
positionner à l'intérieur et la même
chose au niveau des Noirs
personnellement j'aime bien c'est joli
c'est sympa ça marche bien ok alors nous
on va regarder les beiges parce que j'ai
testé sur les Belges et en fait ça vient
se positionner comme ça vous avez votre
oreille vous prenez vous faites le tour
et Tac ça vient se caler directement ici
sur votre oreille une fois de plus c'est
super simple donc là vous avez le
conduit auditif qui est là et vous avez
un scooter qui est juste sur le dessus
vient reposer sur votre oreille voyez il
vient faire tout le monde oreille comme
ça et alors c'est plutôt bien balancé
parce que derrière vous avez en fait une
batterie juste ici qui permet vraiment
de faire l'équilibre lorsque vous l'avez
autour de l'oreille ça bouge pas c'est
pratique c'est sympa ça c'est plutôt
cool donc ça c'est bien et en plus c'est
vraiment confort on va se positionner
directement tout seul dans votre rail
vous êtes peinard on se parle donc
d'écouteurs qui sont construits autour
de l'oreille ils vont bien évidemment
s'adapter à toutes les formes d'oreilles
sans aucun problème grâce au crochet
auriculaire qu'ils appellent arc de
dauphin ouais ben demandez pas pourquoi
alors on se parle ici d'écouteurs qui
font 8,3 g c'est pas très lourd donc on
les sent pas autour de l'oreille il y a
pas de souci ici alors vous allez me
dire tout ça
c'est bien petit mais qu'en est-il au
niveau de l'audio j'appuie sur le bouton
qui arrive et comme j'ai mis les Guns je
sais pas où est mon téléphone ça
commence ça envoie un peu du bois voilà
ça c'est la musique surprend réellement
alors vous allez voir qu'en fait vous
avez un appui si je fais un double tape
mais play double table je mets pause
regardez redouble ta pause voilà ça me
coupe la musique alors tout ça bien
évidemment dans une application je vais
vous expliquer un peu l'audio parce que
on va se dire ok ça c'est plutôt bien
mais pour autant tu n'as rien qui rentre
dans les oreilles et tu as forcément un
petit peu de perte de son alors c'est
pas forcément vrai c'est pas forcément
faux fatalement et bien c'est vrai que
lorsque vous allez pas avoir des
écouteurs qui vont venir directement
dans votre canal auditif ou alors avec
un casque qui va venir vous envoyer le
son directement pour arriver en direct
dans votre rail on va se dire ok il y a
une petite paire légère très très légère
mais pour autant il y a un truc qui est
vraiment intéressant avec Open fit ici
c'est qu'ils sont vraiment venus
travailler avec des algorithmes pour
venir maximiser l'expérience et vous
permettre de profiter d'une bonne
expérience audio et globalement le taf
est vraiment bien fait alors ils ont une
technologie qui s'appelle direct pitch
et d'ailleurs cette techno on vient en
fait récupérer des graves et des aigus
vous emmener le son qui est directement
en haut jusque dans votre conduit
auditif en fait c'est comme une espèce
de petite glissade paf ça arrive dans
votre oreille sans oublier un algo qui
va venir compenser aussi pour apporter
un peu plus de fréquence basse puisque
on se parle et vous le voyez quand même
ici un petit haut-parleur qui est là et
qui vient envoyer le son directement
c'est pas de la conduction osseuse ici
c'est vraiment le son qui sort du
haut-parleur là et ici juste en dessous
pour venir récupérer et vous ramener un
peu plus de fréquence basse et que ça
ronronne et globalement le taf est quand
même plutôt pas mal fichu alors j'ai
remis les gars on remet la poche tout ça
ça se fait aussi directement dans une
application et ça c'est cool
l'application forcément elle va porter
le nom de la marque et dans cette
application il y a des trucs qui sont
vraiment cool je vous montre déjà le
fait de pouvoir paramétrer son égaliseur
alors vous le voyez au dessus avant
l'égaliseur vous avez vos niveaux de
batterie à droite et à gauche mais là
vous avez vraiment votre égaliseur et ça
je trouve ça vraiment vraiment bien
parce que ça permet de venir faire un
petit peu au custom customiser alors
vous avez différents modes de base de
base vous avez le mode standard qui est
un flat complet toutes les fréquences à
zéro pas mal après les autres je les
aime pas trop vocal vient trop monter
les médiums basque trop de basse et
trouve pas très jolie comme ça des aigus
trop déguses moi ce que je vous
conseille vraiment c'est de venir dans
le custom et je vais venir personnaliser
moi j'ai fait ça et c'est ce que en tout
cas ce que mon oreille aime et moi
j'aime est-ce que je viendrai en tout
cas vous recommander d'essayer bien
évidemment si c'est les écouteurs vous
intéressent une fois de plus je vous
mets le lien en bas dans la description
à savoir que je suis venu remonter un
peu de basse alors on a cinq banques de
fréquences attention c'est pas la folie
non plus on va se calmer tout de suite
vous venez monter légèrement les 64
Hertz de toute façon bon c'est juste
histoire de rapporter un peu de rondeur
vous montez un petit peu laissant air
très légèrement le kilo ici touchez pas
au 4 kg et vous montez un petit peu le 8
kg même niveau que les 100 Hertz pour
venir rapporter un petit peu de
fraîcheur un peu de clarté au niveau des
aigus et là le son je le trouve bien et
il va être maximisé et après vous pouvez
venir en créer d'autres alors moi j'ai
customisé celui-là parce que c'est ce
que je veux dire préférer si vous vous
dites ok je vais me créer un autre
custom sur de la musique jazz par
exemple ou j'en sais rien vous pouvez
venir le faire ou pour des films ou pour
des séries parce que bien évidemment ces
écouteurs là on peut les utiliser pour
écouter de la musique mais également
vous revisionner des films et des séries
tout en sachant ici à titre d'infos que
vous avez des codes assez et SBC c'est
tout pas plus pas bon alors des
écouteurs comme ça c'est bien c'est beau
mais pourquoi faire alors bien
évidemment il y a plein d'usage derrière
on va s'en douter l'idée de ces
écouteurs c'est de rester ouvert au
monde c'est-à-dire je veux être tout le
temps
dans mon environnement je vais pouvoir
aussi bien être au bureau écouter de la
musique et puis converser avec des
collègues sans aucun problème entendre
si quelqu'un me parle et toujours rester
attentif avec la même chose à la maison
si par exemple et bien moi j'ai
Elliot qui est pas loin de pouvoir
entendre ce que me dit mon fils tiens il
m'appelle papa ok j'arrive je suis pas
loin je peux regarder pour autant un
film une série j'entends ce qui se passe
et ça c'est plutôt bien de la même
manière si vous voulez aller faire du
sport vous pouvez aller faire du sport
avec et être attentif et ça je pense
notamment aux personnes qui vont aller
courir aller faire un footing dans la
rue par exemple et bien maman si vous
croisez des voitures c'est quand même
plutôt bien d'être attentif et de savoir
ce qui se passe si vous rencontrez
quelqu'un pareil vous vous arrêtez vous
pouvez lui parler ou alors si vous êtes
dans la rue vous écoutez de la musique
vous rentrez dans un magasin hop je
voudrais prendre un café ainsi je peux
le faire sans problème et puis bien
évidemment ces écouteurs sont là pour
écouter de la musique mais pas que je
vous disais des films et des séries mais
également pour les appels téléphoniques
donc vous marchez tac vous pouvez
répondre à un appel parler à quelqu'un
en même temps bah tiens attends je vais
demander ça à quelqu'un vous posez la
question vous pouvez répondre vous avez
les oreilles libres et quand même
vachement bien ils ont fait un truc qui
est assez intéressant aussi il nous
annonce que lors de vos appels
téléphoniques ils viennent réduire le
bruit ambiant
99,7% et last note list vous allez avoir
7 heures d'autonomie par écouteur et
vous montez jusqu'à 28 heures grâce à
votre boîtier de recharge le truc qui
est aussi plutôt cool lorsque vous
commencez à manquer d'autonomie et bien
vous le recharger 5 minutes et vous être
reparti pour une amie je vais vous
parler il y a quelques instants que
lorsque je les mets j'appuie paf ça me
déclenche du son pourquoi et bien parce
qu'en fait vous avez des petites
commandes tactile sur vos écouteurs et
vous pouvez venir également les
customiser dans l'application c'est
quand même vachement bien alors regardez
vous venez ici customisation des boutons
par défaut c'est deux tapes à droite et
à gauche Lecture pause vous appuyez et
vous maintenez gauche morceau précédent
droit morceau suivant vous pouvez venir
dessus et complètement dire
personnaliser l'histoire là par exemple
par défaut à droite et à gauche c'est
Lecture pause vous pouvez mettre Lecture
pause à gauche et morceau suivant à
droite ou alors lecture pose à gauche
morceau précédent à droite ou alors
carrément Lecture pause à gauche et
l'assistant vocal de votre téléphone à
droite c'est pas mal non plus et pareil
pour appuyer maintenir vous pouvez
baisser le volume et augmenter le volume
ou alors carrément l'assistant vocal à
vous de voir ça dépend vraiment de ce
que vous voulez en faire et après vous
avez quelques petits paramètres
supplémentaires ici alors les réglages
vont vous donner l'égalisation la mise à
jour du firmware économiser les boutons
la lampe de l'application qui va être la
langue de votre smartphone par défaut un
mode son vous souhaitez avoir un mode
son surtout qui est pas mal c'est le
mode d'emploi qui est vraiment bien
fourni vous explique absolument tout
vous êtes 39 pages donc vous pouvez y
aller on entretient le port l'achat la
LED l'entretien bref vous avez tout tout
qui est ici donc si vous en avez besoin
et vous attendez déplacement
réinitialiser la connexion automatique
et bien tout est clair bien expliqué ici
je trouve ça vachement bien autre point
et comme je vous le disais tout à
l'heure pour les utiliser pour aller
faire du sport et
quand on croise quelques gouttes parce
qu'il se met à pleuvoir et bien sachez
que vos écouteurs sont certifiés
résistants à l'eau IP à 54 alors
attention on va pas se baigner avec
soyons clair et si vous avez des
éclaboussures ça fonctionnera
parfaitement bien par les sites des
écouteurs je parle pas du boîtier le
boîtier du par contre il est pas du tout
certifié donc on y va tranquille avec la
collection est stable ce que j'ai
entendu j'ai eu aucun problème il y a du
Bluetooth 5.2 à l'intérieur et ils sont
disponibles à partir du 6 juillet 2023
au tarif de 199 euros choisissez votre
couleur soit le beige soit le noir bien
évidemment une fois de plus je vous mets
le lien juste en bas dans la description
donc si vous cherchez vraiment une
alternative si des bugs ne vous vont pas
si vous ne voulez pas de casque si vous
voulez avoir les oreilles libres et être
attentif au monde qui vous entourent et
bien vous pouvez aller sur les chocs
open fille que je trouve très sympa 199
euros le tarif est maîtriser les
produits sont de qualité ça fonctionnera
bien voilà donc si vous intéresse une
fois de plus le lien est en bas dans la
description alors dites-moi est-ce que
c'est des produits qui pourraient vous
intéresser est-ce que le fait d'avoir un
casque comme ça et voyez je fais toute
la vidéo avec tout en ayant les oreilles
qui sont libres et de fait de pouvoir
vous parler sans aucun problème est-ce
que ce genre de solution pourrait vous
intéresser est-ce que vous vous sentez à
l'aise est-ce que quelqu'un qui vous
parle et bien et des écouteurs puisse
écouter un filet de musique ou pas et
qu'il vous entend très bien que c'est
des choses qui vous plaisent ok moi ça
bien évidemment dans les commentaires et
nous on se retrouve très bientôt pour
continuer à parler tech je vous embrasse
prenez soin de vous et à bientôt Ciao